we have new information on the five
people killed in a twin-engine plane
crash in Santa Ana California dashcam
video just released shows the plane
falling from the sky headfirst into a
parked car outside a strip mall
yesterday first responders say it's hard
to believe no one on the ground was hurt
the plane went down only one mile from
its destination
Matea VA al is near the crash site where
federal investigators work through the
night Matea good morning well good
morning all of the victims actually
worked for a real estate consulting firm
that was based in Northern California
some of them were actually related to
each other now this could have been way
worse as you just said Vlad right now
because we are in a high-traffic area a
lot of stores and restaurants nearby and
yesterday was a very busy shopping day
dashcam video shows the twin-engine
Cessna as it fell from the sky around
12:30 Sunday afternoon none of the five
people on board survived cell phone
video shows the chaotic scene just after
the plane crash into an Orange County
parking lot smashing into a car that car
was actually unoccupied and part
fortunately that person was inside the
store shopping at the time of impact
nearby shoppers say the fixed-wing
aircraft made a sputtering noise as it
dropped headfirst into the ground the
FAA says the pilot identified as scott
shepard declared an emergency just
before the crash
it's mariko then nobody else got hurt
shepard was the owner of a san francisco
real estate consulting firm category 3
aviation corporation the coroner has
identified the other victims as Lyra
Shepard Floria and Naveed Hachi me and
Nasim got ad on the plane had taken off
from Concord heading for John Wayne
Airport in Santa Ana just about 1 mile
from the crash Floria posted a photo to
Instagram about two hours before the
crash with the caption flying out to LA
the plane she was boarding appears to
have the same markings as the one that
crashed it does look like it came down
pretty abruptly
there's a small impact zone federal
investigators are now trying to
determine why the plane went down
so close to its final destination I
don't know anything about what this
pilot did or what he was thinking but it
could have been much more tragic the
fact that there was no injuries on the
ground is a miracle on itself
the victims were on their way to a real
estate conference that's supposed to be
here in Orange County and the pilot
we've learned he has years of experience
in fact he had just renewed his pilot's
license last year gale Wow thank you
madam a you've got a miracle and tragedy
too it's always tough guys to see
Instagram pictures or any picture we you
know that was probably the last picture
taken of the person the investigation of
course continues there